This coin is called a penny.
A penny is worth only one cent.
The word 'cent' is used when talking about coins.
This is the cent symbol.
Okay, let's use our tens blocks to compare the worth or value of this coin.
The penny is only worth one cent as we see here.
This next coin is called a nickel.
A nickel is worth five cents.
These five ones blocks represent the value of this nickel.
So the penny is worth one cent and the nickel is worth five cents.
Our next coin is smaller than the nickel and the penny.
But just as we learned with the ring and the rock, the size is not important.
This coin is called a dime.
A dime is worth ten cents.
We can see this with one of our tens blocks.
This tens block has ten block in it.
So it represents the dime.
So the penny is worth one cent,...
...the nickel is worth five cents,...
...and the dime is worth ten cents.
Our last coin is called a quarter.
A quarter is worth 25 cents.
To show 25 cents with our blocks, we would need 25 blocks right?
So to get 25 blocks, we need two tens blocks and five ones blocks.